you talk a lot about and i talk a lot
about chemical toxins that we encounter
inside the home that we encounter
outside the home and what that stuff
really does to the body so can you talk
a little bit about things that people
encounter in their everyday lives
cleaning products furniture clothing
whatever it is that you feel detergent
makeup beauty products
and what's going on that's wrong there
and how that can contribute to people
feeling ultimately sick
when it comes to environmental toxins it
is one of the most
insidious
uh agents or influences on our health uh
for the negative
uh and as you know we're not taught
about this in school and it's definitely
not in the mainstream media
and a hundred percent you're not going
to your conventional doctor's office and
they're asking you about your cleaning
supplies or your personal care products
or what is your furniture or what that
are you sleeping on
but it's just as important if not more
important
when i was and i know we're going to
cancer working on cancer patients i
actually derived at the end of
my time when i was a clinician
uh before i went into media
i saw that environmental toxins was one
of two
of the leading causes of cancer
beyond what we understand right so many
of us talk about really healthy eating
and that plays a role i think
environmental medicine and environmental
toxins play more of a role than healthy
eating and cancer as well as the other
thing that we'll talk about which is the
emotions
so when i talk about environmental
toxins in environmental medicine
it's really is what are the things in
our environment in our home and our work
that are having an adverse effect on our
health
there's many things that we're breathing
in putting in our skin and in our mouth
that have a chemical effect on our body
so they disrupt our hormones they cause
inflammation
they disrupt our immune system our
neurological system
for example let's say we all a lot of us
at this point have heard about bpa now
bpa is one of the biggest endocrine
disruptors meaning it really disrupts
your hormones men and women i actually
attribute the
increase or the increase in disruption
of estrogen balance testosterone balance
in men and women i think the biggest
cause is bpa and phthalates and it's
because that's everywhere see the cdc a
few years ago
did a study and and tested over 2000
people's urine and and bpa is something
that's metabolized within 24 hours 48
hours
and in over 93 of these people
they found bpa in there meaning within
the past one or two days
over 93 of that 2000 plus people
had bpa exposure it's a big problem
because what bpa does is it it it's an
agonist for estrogen meaning that it
binds to the receptors for estrogen and
then starts having an estrogenic effect
in men and women which is not a good
thing we have a very certain amount an
elegant symphony of hormones and we
don't want to disrupt that and bpa is
one of the first things to disrupt that
but that's in plastic bottles thermal
paper receipts the lining of cans
tunicans beans tomato sauce
it is in
shower curtains that that we're exposing
ourselves to right anything that has
plastic wrapping right anything where
there's food in there that's bpa and
it's everywhere so that's just one of
many but then we have to start expanding
our thinking into what's in our home are
we are we in a couch that's off gassing
or are we in a couch that has a
certification that shows us okay no
we've tested for over 3000 different
chemicals that don't off gas because
not on the first day not on the second
or the even the first year but at some
point it starts affecting you certainly
your children certainly your pets can
you just talk i don't want to interrupt
that but off gassing use that term
that's a common term that we use in the
wellness community not everybody will
understand that right away so what do
you mean by that in terms of off-gassing
and and
what comes out a couch for example
that's something a bed things that have
that cushion or foam what is coming out
into the air and what what do you see in
a child does that cause asthma like what
well how does that measure the body
so say for example i'm sitting on a
couch now um this one's been tested but
if this was a conventional couch that i
bought at the conventional store uh the
polyurethane especially the same thing
that is in tempur-pedic beds right that
foam
um
sometimes it's the upholstery
and a lot of the time it's the wood the
plywood
uh the glues that are sticking together
the wood all of these chemicals these
materials they have chemical uh
constituents and when those bonds start
breaking down over time right it starts
degrading they they become uh volatile
and these compounds are breathed in
right and when that when you hear the
word off-gassing say for example i'll
give you an example of off-gassing you
ever smell bleach that's the chemical
off-gassing into the air into your
respiratory system into your lungs so
naturally something uh that would be of
effect is in children or us is
respiratory issues respiratory disease
so
let's say for example someone's
listening and they go
uh my kid out of nowhere just developed
asthma my kid keeps having sinus issues
or sinusitis they're not breathing well
at night it could very well be that that
new couch that you bought two months ago
is adversely affecting your child if
your dog is having issues itching
nonstop right it could very well be that
there's something in the home that your
dog is allergic to uh and then us as
adults same thing
this when it's not just couches too one
of the biggest things is bed and i just
mentioned the tempur-pedic one of the
worst beds that you could possibly have
that is off-gassing for the life of it
you can't just put it outside for a week
and
you know the smell is gone and then
bring it in for the life of that bed or
for the life of the couch it's off
gassing that phenomenon which is really
affecting us and it's not just
respiratory over time these are known
carcinogenic chemicals not all of them
but many of them for example
formaldehyde these are known
carcinogenic chemicals which cause
cancer so if we are exposed to something
in a slow drip every single day at home
and it can lead to cancer at some point
it would just behoove us to bring more
education into okay well what are the
other options yeah and you know what's
interesting i had right i don't know if
you know this about me i had lyme
disease several years ago i got a
diagnosis and i had a tempur-pedic bed
and i didn't know any better at the time
and i was laying on it every night and i
was getting severe headaches and i was
lucky enough to have a doctor that was a
functional medicine doctor that said oh
my gosh you've got to get rid of that
bed today and it's interesting i got rid
of it within a week all of those
headaches left and it was day after day
and i'm not prone to migraine so it was
an interesting little experiment if you
like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]